aujourd'hui le philosophe benny lévy on
soir alors vous êtes extrêmement rare à
la télévision on est d'autant plus
flatté et honoré que vous soyez là ce
soir benny lévy vous êtes en egypte
ensuite s'est exilé en europe ensuite
vous êtes le mystérieux patron de la
gauche prolétarienne pierre victor vous
êtes le dernier secrétaire de jean paul
sartre dont vos entretiens avec lui ont
renversé carrément son oeuvre
et aujourd'hui vous êtes à jérusalem où
vous étudiez la torah et où vous dirigez
l'institut d'études lévinassiennes
d'après le philosophe levinas dont on
parlera bien entendu un petit peu plus
tard voilà ça c'est le tableau général
alors maintenant c'est concerne le devis
proprement dit vous êtes né en 45 au
caire en egypte père dans l'import
export mais assis à gauche a lui même ça
mais assez absent alors famille pas très
religieuse 1
au départ et j'ai quand même grandi chez
migrants par oui il y avait un grand
père effectivement qu'il y avait une
figure très forte pour moi film de rabat
oui absolument mais bon chez vous votre
mère était sioniste dans les années 30
mais au moment où vous nécessaire en 45
la flamme c'est un petit peu et un teint
de son sionisme est moins brûlant une
luciole mais pas alors chez vous c'était
plutôt une vocation je dirais
révolutionnaire puisque votre grand père
maternel était le chef d'un groupe rival
de celui d'henri curiel dr il finira au
bagne
comme votre frère aîné 10 en dit long
disons alors justement parlez jamais de
ce frère vous parlez de votre frère tony
assez assez volontiers vous parlez
jamais de ce frère est en fait j'ai
découvert en préparant cette interview
que c'était lui qui signait sous le nom
de mahmoud hussein et son nom c'est adel
rifaat
il a pris le nom d'un des deux rives ati
signe avec bagatelle nadi sous le nom de
mahmoud hussein un certain nombre de
tribunes souvent dans libération par
exemple on voit des tribunes signait
mahmoud hussein qu'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est à dire il est il s'est
converti à l'islam il est devenu
égyptien et j'ai converti pour la
commodité et pas par conviction parce
qu'il voulait se marier avec une
l'égyptienne musulmane et aussi parce
que il était dans le mouvement
communiste égyptien dans l'intestin plus
proche de votre frère tony tony donc
avec qui vous faites des études au lycée
français du caire et alors vous
finalement vous vous la langue que vous
parlez avec vos parents quand vous étiez
enfant c'était le français voilà moi je
pourrais dire qu'un jour derrida indique
il me plaît beaucoup j'ai qu'une seule
langue mais c'est pas la mienne
ouais et en plus c'est tout à fait par
hasard peut être l'anglais c'est c'est
un peu grâce à bonaparte si vous voulez
que je parle le français est alors en
revanche avec vos grands parents vous
parler l'arabe
oui l'arabe syrien alors vous avez été
élevé dans une egypte un peu un
continent disparaît un pays fantôme un
peu c'est cette egypte d'avant 56 c'est
à dire dont on parle du real évidemment
dont tu parles aussi youssef chahine
volontiers c'est à dire cosmopolite
tolérante et assez libre je n'en sais
rien ah ben non détrompez vous non mais
j'ai dit dans la communauté juive
oui quelque chose a pas eu d'accord
connais rien de l'egypte devrait cette
egypte la wii et puis alors tout bascule
au moment de moments de suez
la sir la guerre donc effectivement vous
avez des souvenirs quand même de votre
père qui écoutent la radio d'israël avec
une serviette sur la tête des caches la
radio ouais parce que il a mal et
hépatiques de peines de prison ou si on
écoutait la radio et la d'histoire
rentrer brusquement dans votre vie à ce
moment là c'est en même temps la hongrie
doute été les les titres des journaux je
me souviens sûr j'ai déjà d'une certaine
manière par communiste évidemment
j'étais trop jeune j'avais 10 ans 10 11
ans mais le mot communisme était déjà un
mot fabuleux je l'avais entendu au pied
du lit de ma mère prononcé par mois par
mon frère est manifestement c'était un
mot d'une rare profondeur
il est resté et l'a cependant oui alors
voilà donc en 56 effectivement beaucoup
sont beaucoup sont expulsés un carrément
d'autres s'accrochent vous vous rester
quelques temps vous jouez au tennis dans
l'est les pièces vides de la maison
familiale
et puis donc à 12 ans en 57 vous partant
l'exil à bruxelles vous arrivez le jour
de carnaval
ce qui était non seulement forme et
qu'il n'a jamais quittée c'est que je
sais pas où je suis arrivé ouais jusqu'à
maintenant j'ai préféré ouais déracinés
mais en plus sa patrie faisait pas de
paris n'avait pas de racines avant oui
mais au moins j'avais un lieu j'avais
une familiarité
depuis elle était cassé alors voilà vous
allez au lycée francophones de bruxelles
vous découvrez sartre par les livres
évidemment vous vous opposez à la guerre
d'algérie et vous êtes un élève
brillantissime un adolescent prodige
mais très provocateur un jouet un
concours d'éloquence en présence de
l'ambassadeur de france et vous faites
tous me disent opérant vous partez sur
l'algérie et vous déclarez
les ce que vous appelez les fellaghas en
fait pour moi ce sont les héroïques
combattant du front de libération
nationale c'était assez gonflé quand
même malgré tout puisque vous êtes
quelqu'un de brillant
vous avez quand même la palme de nulle
part ans j'ai occuper tout le terrain
voilà était pas possible de faire
autrement
et le lendemain on fait la une des
journaux oui et je devais être donc
j'avais le prix donc je vais aller au
maroc un gouvernement marocain a refusé
le visa parce que j'étais juif
ouais le gouvernement marocain qui met
pas le pire ouais ouais c'est vrai c'est
vrai voilà puis après bon vous venez en
france et alors là à paris vous faites
la connaissance de pierre goldman le
frère de jean jacques goldman qui avait
écrit enfin qui a écrit les souvenirs
d'un juif polonais né en france
et puis vous connaissez aussi finalement
à ce moment là un certain nombre de gens
qui sont plus tard les artisans du
gauchisme français nous fait normale sup
voilà et alors là autour d'althusser se
constitue l'union des jeunes communistes
marxistes léninistes si l'époque des
comités vietnam de base c'est sympa
ensuite c'est 68 la la la la victoire de
de gaulle en juin 68 les lecteurs des
gaullistes le grand défilé des champs
elysées et la ligue en a qui arrêtent
d'ailleurs et puis les irréductibles se
regroupe autour de vous c'est la gauche
prolétarienne et vous prenez un nom de
un nom de guerre qui est pierre victor
alors allez peuple vous vous sentez pas
juifs à l'époque vous vous le cacher
maintenant ce que vous racontez pire le
premier congrès ouvriers qu'on a fait ce
qui était un exploit quand même pour un
petit groupe gauchiste
on a dû faire à bruxelles c'est un 70
est donc déjà les prêts les ouvriers
étaient surtout les ouvriers arabes et
j'ai dû entendre un propos antisémite
d'une violence rare d'un cadre de
roubaix je me souviens et je me suis tu
ouais mais c'est la honte la honte parce
que je représentais le prolétariat et
donc je ne pouvais pas diviser comme
j'étais le chef est donc j'étais folle
de base en un donc en soixante dix vous
rencontrez savent pour la pour la
première fois parce que les dirigeants
de la cause du peuple se font arrêter
les uns après les autres par qu'un jour
vous
dit finalement il n'y a qu'un qui peut
nous qui peut nous aider c'est ça il
accepte assez facilement et vous vous
êtes chargé des contacts avec lui pour
arranger vous faites une espèce de
liaison entre il était même il était
même le seul intellectuel qui je
soumettais des problèmes voilà alors
donc on en arrive à munich après munich
effectivement là c'est la fin de la
gauche prolétarienne
nous on a créé des comités palestine
parce que je m'amuse quand j'entends
maintenant l'opinion européenne pro
palestinienne
croyez moi en 70 ça ne l'était pas et
quelques autres nous avons inventé le
palestinien mais c'était sur une base
strict on devait être antisioniste
alors surtout pas antisémite n'oubliez
pas que nous sommes une génération pour
qu'ils agissent rester là legrand
interdite alors on avait des militants
arabes qui se baladait dans les rues en
dix ans lise effet die le journal
antisémite ou leur disais non
il corrige d'accord jusqu'à ce que
munich publiquement montrent qu'il n'y
avait pas des poings nus des
palestiniens de différence entre les
deux voilà des munich c'est l'attentât
des palestiniens contre des athlètes
israéliens alors doit effectivement vous
comme finalement votre fond de militants
c'était quand même souvent ddos
d'origine arabe
donc à un moment il n'y a plus de vide à
mansart et m'a pas grand chose c'est un
peu ce qui s'est passé au moment de la
guerre du golfe pour sos racisme
d'ailleurs css racisme a commencé à
imploser
au moment de la guerre du golfe ou d'un
seul coup des des juifs et des musulmans
qui étaient dans cette organisation dans
ce trou sont trouvés opposé par par
l'actualité par l'histoire et c'était un
peu la fin c'est un peu la même chose
d'une certaine façon ce qui s'est passé
pour la fin de la gauche prolétarienne
voilà alors là ensuite pour financer le
journal libération
vous vous entreprenez avec sartre et
philippe gavi
un ouvrage un livre et à ce moment là
sartre à son accident de santé qui le
rendra
wingles et alors vous êtes toujours
apatride et donc je vous engage comme
secrétaire donc à ce moment là c'est
j'imagine que ça permettait pour vous
d'avoir des papiers d'être reconnu par
là mais j'étais en assignation de
résidence de fait c'est un homme que je
devais aller tous les dix ou quinze
jours à la préfecture de nanterre où
commissaire de police de boulogne pour
faire acte de présence etc on ne
renouvelle un papier qui était qu un
papier qui me convenait pour 15 jours à
paris c'était sans arrêt renouveler sans
arrêt et sans arrêt je devais aller avec
un avocat ou en m'envoyant lozère
n'était pas très drôle alors voilà donc
vous devenez le secrétaire de sartre
chaque matin vous rendez au 29 boulevard
clean et aux escaliers à 2 10e étage
puis l'après-midi ou fait autre chose
mais vous commencé à vous intéresser à
levinas et vous commencez à apprendre
l'hébreu
alors est ce qu'on pourrait dire que
c'est un judaïsme un peu compassionnel
voir un peu christianisé on pourrait
dire ça de levinas tout ça vous fait
hurler quand je vous dis ça ça me fait
d'accord
cela dit il y en a certains qui veulent
en faire de lui cela alors elle est au
contraire à une époque où vraiment
personne ne songez que dans les vieux
textes juifs dans ses vieux grimoires il
y avait de la pensée non seulement il
l'a dit mais la pratique et il l'a
montré
moi j'ai je me suis mis à apprendre
l'hébreu parce que j'ai soupçonné et
derrière la prose exceptionnelle de
levinas qui avaient un horizon qui est l
horizon d'hébreu way et donc je devais
j'ai été sommée d'y aller il est un
maître pour moi pour ça parce qu'il m'a
obligé à apprendre apprendre l'hébreu
donc levinas qu'il a fait si on voulait
résumer comme ça c'est que ça a été le
premier à dépasser le politique pour
retourner vers le messianisme les tirs
d'une façon oui
alors ce qui est extraordinaire à ce
moment là c'est que sartre et est très
impressionné par votre recherche
lévinassiennes il suit le cheminement de
votre pensée à partir du gauchisme vers
le vert le judaïsme est ici un jour il
vous dit ah tu as jeunes et pour kippour
c'est à dire que et d'un seul coup il
découvre quelque chose que finalement
ils avaient complètement oblitéré chez
lui il sentait des choses qui se passent
en moi que moi j'étais incapable de
d'expliciter mais qui m'avait déjà
frappé ces différences entre les choses
qui était en moi parce qu'elle m'avait
frappé les choses que j'ai dont je
pouvais rendre compte est la chose la
plus importante de cette période et lui
de l'extérieur il est très sensible à ce
mouvement de subjectivation chez moi a
vu des choses mieux il m'a obligé à
retourner à mon nom propre
oui donc vous a aidé avant la
nationalité française enfin ce qui est
quand même a été utile est en sursis
vous a redonné votre nom quand l'annoncé
a été faite enfin la réponse de giscard
d'estaing était donné si simone de
beauvoir qui m'a ouvert la porte et puis
j'ai sauté de joie et elle m'a dit comme
quoi elle n'a pas compris comme vous l'a
dit iphone vous expliquer pourquoi ces
joyeux croyait alors contre
l'incompréhension votre naturalisation
pompidou l'avait refusée
bien avant alors que j'étais son
condisciple anarchie cubes de l'école
normale et monsieur le directeur l'école
28 rire qui lui avait demandé
personnellement il avait refusé alors
évidemment un moment il ya un énorme
scandale séquences ont publié dans le
nouvel observateur des entretiens avec
avec ça je dis bien des entretiens parce
que ce n'était pas une interview c'était
entretien d'égal à égal
et puis ensuite on a dit oui c'est des
trucs l'autre il était malade alitée sur
son lit de mort pas du tout c'est des
choses que vous aviez discuté pendant de
longues années ensemble je veux dire je
te dis ça parce que souvent on a une
vision un peu un peu courte de cette
affaire et il ya eu des témoignages ne
serait-ce que celui de jean daniel le
dirai aux amateurs puisque ça lui a
téléphoné en lui disant j'ai relu avec
arlette mots de cet entretien je signe
chaque mot et jean daniel avait allumé
je crois pour tous les journalistes et
donc oui d'une certaine manière ça m'a
sauvé oui parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
parlé de translation savent
s'autocritique déjà ensuite on a parlé
de trahison on a parlé de parjure c'est
un seul coup ils remettaient en cause
tout ce qu'ils avaient fait jusque là il
dit par exemple j'ai beaucoup parlé
d'angoissé de désespoir mais j'étais un
peu victime de la mode
alors évidemment d'un seul coup tous les
to les sartrien classiques disent on a
jamais laissé très classique donnant
clairement une femme une femme qui est
venue presque m'insulter pas dire
comment c'est tolérable
j'avais issus idées pour ça alors voilà
en gros ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
sartre à la fin de sa viste finalement
il remet tout en cause y jette un peu sa
philosophie au panier il veut tout
refonder à partir de la bible le
judaïsme et c'est là il parle même de
résurrection des corps ce qui fait sa
renommée attention ce qu'il voulait
c'est en faire quelque chose de manière
laïque sarthe n'était pas devenu croyant
la fin de ces dépasse convertir mais
c'est vrai que d'un seul coup ils
prenaient convertir les mêmes pour lui
et même avoir un rapport propre au divin
ce n'était pas ça son problème
oui problème c'était 2 à partir des
textes juifs de refonder de renouveler
là la pensée dite de gauche ils
l'auraient encore lui comme il l'a à
partir du messianisme d'un seul coup ils
découvraient que le messianisme était
supérieur à la politique d'une certaine
façon oui ça oui on peut le dire mais
c'est l'extrême qu'on peut le dire
d'accord a pas une fondation à partir de
là non mais c'est bien que vous en
parler parce que c'est vrai qu'à ce
moment là on vous a accusé de
détournement de deux vieillards
vous dites qu on a dit que vous avez
obligé sa hargne et sa pensée que tu as
et vous vous avez pas répondu vous savez
j'étais complètement assommé ouais non
parce que vous oublié l'essentiel c'est
que on avait simone de beauvoir sont
entre nous et vous voyez ce que ces
démos de beaux arts c'était quand même
alain py intellectuelle pas à cause de
son rapport à sartre était devenu public
que son rapport était fissurée par ma
propre existence mais c'était un empire
et moi j'étais un rien du tout donc été
jeté dans la cage aux lions près et donc
mais d'ailleurs c'est une très très
bonne épreuve parce que ça m'a permis de
m'isoler encore plus et donc d'accentuer
mon mouvement de pensée propre est alors
au début des années 80 donc à un moment
où tous les anciens de la gauche
prolétarienne font de la publicité
dirige des journaux font la télévision
et qui vous tfou il y en a qui sont
toujours pour enfin bon il y en a
beaucoup qui sont installés quand les
safram et à ce moment là vous partez à
strasbourg pour étudier le talmud puis à
jérusalem où vous êtes donc actuellement
est alors quand vous parlez de ça
maintenant c'est terrible ce que vous
dites
quand je pense que j'ai commencé par
platon j'ai perdu beaucoup de temps avec
plateau ah si j'avais commencé par rabbi
akiba
qu'est ce qu'il a dit ce rabbi akiba
d'extraordinaire qu'est-ce que pourquoi
vous dites ça a bien qui base c'est le
coeur de toute la tradition de ce qu'on
appelle l'enseignement oral en plus
bouleversantes puisqu'il a été
atrocement torturé par là je vais par
les romains les les années que j'ai
passées à apprendre des mots de grecs
parce que j'en ai passé je venais le
grec comme sacrement
c'est autant d'années de perdus pour mes
études talmudiques qui demande qui
demande de clémence du temps mais pas du
temps une vie nuit jour et nuit vous
avez perdu quoi 25 ans pas voilà à peu
près ouais voilà à peu près
non et c'est une perte qui à certains
égards et irréversible parce que des
gens me disent mais avec la culture que
tu as etc tu interroges mieux les textes
ça c'est exactement ce que marc exact
mais ce que j'ai perdu c'est
l'inscription de dans un an une âme
jeûnerait des premiers textes
cet accès direct immédiat qu'ont les
enfants pleins et c'était la version et
c'était alors pourquoi aujourd'hui
l'engagement politique vous semble vain
il sait pas qu'il est vain c'est que je
vais reprendre votre expression il
conduit à l'impasse et à dire on
s'engage politiquement parce qu'on a un
très très grand désir
là je laisse de côté tout ce qui
brouille ce désir voire une certaine
fuite devant soi même et c'est je prends
la chose sous son angle de grandeur
alors on s'engage à travers ce à partir
de ce désir
et puis ce désir vous fourvoie
complètement et donc je suis retrouvé
quand j'étais militant de plus en plus à
naître faut un être qui n'était plus moi
même alors ça avait des avantages pour
moi puisque j'étais un apatride
clandestins que je devais quelque part
faire le français donc c'était juste
d'être un peu faux
donc ça c'est l avantage personnel que
je retirais mais les braves gens qui
n'avaient pas mon problème et n'ont même
pas eu ce bénéfice est donc ils allaient
droit droit contre le mur et je parle
pour aujourd'hui je vois les gens ils se
remettent à se remobiliser pour des pour
des produits pour des causes politiques
la lutte contre la mondialisation je dis
ça me semble vain
mais les pots et pauvres je parle d'eux
ouais enfin pas des pauvres dont ils
parlent d eux-mêmes dépôt tec en fait la
seule chose qui vaille la peine pour
vous aujourd'hui c'est d'études de ces
textes trouver la vérité qui est au fond
de ses textes mais aimer ça ça me lira à
tous c'est à dire le rêve politique et
que deux mois à j'aille à tous bon ne
prendra plus la forme du rassemblement
ouais du rassemblement qui est aussi
bien stalinien kke hitlériennes mais une
toute autre forme vrai altérité quoi
voilà une configuration de d'être unique
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
inler du tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux